there's
people
that have lived through something
that can comment in a very specific way
like for example holocaust survivors yes
there is a sense in which maybe a basic
sense of civility
when a holocaust survivor is speaking
about their experience of the holocaust
than um
an intellectual
from a very different part of the world
that's simply writing about uh nuanced
geopolitics of world war ii
just
should not interrupt the holocaust
survivor we physically interrupt them if
they're telling their stories
with logic
and reason that the experience of the
holocaust survivor somehow fundamentally
has a deeper understanding of the
humanity
and the injustice of that first of all
again when even deeper water is now but
in terms of wanting to listen to another
person who has experienced something yes
yes
but not endlessly
not endlessly
i mean there are some people who've
written about i mean there are people
who've written about the holocaust who
didn't experience the holocaust and have
written about it better than people who
did
it's it's not
this this this idea that the lived
experience to use this terrible modern
jargon
as if there's another type
this this this idea that the lived
experience has to triumph over
everything else is is not always correct
it can be correct in some circumstances
if you are sitting in a room with a
holocaust survivor and somebody who'd
never heard about the holocaust and
wanted to kind of you know shoot out
their views on it
yeah one of those people should be heard
more than the other obviously obviously
if there's somebody who's experienced
racism first hand and there's somebody
else who has never experienced it
then obviously you'd want to hear from
the person who has experienced it
firsthand if that is the discussion
underway
i i don't think that it's the case that
that is endlessly the
case i'm also
highly reluctant to concede
that there are groups of people who by
didn't of their skin color or anything
else
get to dominate the microphone of course
we're literally both speaking to
microphones at the moment so there's an
irony to this but let's skate over the
irony
what i mean is people saying you don't
have the right to speak i have the right
to take the microphone from you and
speak because i know best
fine
if you know best we'll argue it out
and someone will win
long or short term
but the
the um
there's the the almost aggressive tone
in which this is now leveled i don't
like the sound of
nobody's experience is completely
understandable by another human being
nobody's
and what many people are asking us to do
at the moment us collectively is
to fall for that thing i think it was
camille faster who said it first but
i've um adopted it in recent years is to
say you must spend an inordinate amount
of your life trying to understand me
personally my lived experience
everything about me you should dedicate
your life to trying to do that
simultaneously you'll never understand
me
this is not an attractive invitation
this is this is a an unwinnable game
so somebody if somebody has a
legitimate
um
and an important point to make they
should make it and they will win through
whatever their character is whatever
their race and by the way there are
plenty of white people who experience
racism as well there are plenty of white
people who do
and have done and increasingly so which
is one of the things i write about in
the war in the west i mean i i would
argue that today in america the only
group you're actually allowed to be
consistently
vilely racist against the white people
if you say disgusting things about black
people in america in 2022 you will be
over
you will be over
if you decide to talk about people's
white tears their white female tears
their white guilt their white privilege
their white rage and all these other
pseudo-pathologizing terms
you'll be just fine you could be the
chairman of joint chiefs of staff you
could lecture at yale university
absolutely fine and the white people
have to suck that up
as if that's fine because there was
racism in another direction in the past
so white people can have racism as well
does that mean that i think that i have
a right or other white people have a
right to dominate the discourse by
talking about their feelings of having
been victim victims of racism no not
particularly because what does that get
us it gets us into an endless cycle of
competitive victimhood am i saying that
white people who've experienced violence
have experienced historically anything
like the violence that was perpetrated
against black people in america
historically obviously not but
you know
what kind of competition do we want to
enter here
and
this is very very important terrain now
in america because there's one other
thing i have to throw in there which is
how do you work out the sincerity of the
claim
how do you work out the sincerity of the
claim being made
at one point uh in my book in this
latest book i referred to
a very useful bit in them in nature and
genealogy of morals
where as you know nietzsche always has
to be treated carefully you know when
people say um i love nietzsche you have
to witch beds
[Laughter]
what exactly do you love about him
but um
he
uh a lot and a lot can be learned from
the answer uh but there are moments in
junior area tomorrow that was very
useful for this book
one of them was the moment when
nietzsche uses a phrase that i've now
stolen for myself appropriated you might
say um
where um where he refers to people who
who tear at wounds long since closed and
then cry about the pain they feel
now
how do you know
how do you know whether the pain is real
how do you know
i'm not saying you can never know
but it's hard
so when somebody says i feel that my
life hasn't gone that well and it's
because of something that was done to my
ancestors 200 years ago
maybe they do feel that
maybe they're right to feel that
maybe they're making it up
maybe they're using it as their reason
for failure in life maybe they're using
it as their reason to not even try
maybe they're using it as their reason
to
smoke weed all day
i don't know you and who does know how
can you work that out
and that's why i come back to this thing
of who are we
to constantly judge in this society
other people who we don't know
and attribute motives to them based on
on
racial or other characteristics
you